we are going to talk a little about completing vision
in practice what problems we
face how a project of this
style is approached what decisions must be made and
care must be taken first of all
who we are we are a
software development company specialized
in machine learning and in  training
on the subject we also work with
this every day and before starting
a bit to level we are going to talk about
what is computer vision what are the
problems that are solved what is
this artificial vision that we are
working on
the iconic applications
we all know them  the cars that drive themselves
with all the difficulties that this
entails a car at 90 kilometers per
hour at 100 kilometers per hour having
to identify which are the pedestrians
the street signs which is the
way to go what the
other cars are doing and  I'm sure they can think of a
lot more very
relevant applications for the road field, I don't know if
any  Once you stop to think that it is
all that this entails behind,
but we are going to try to talk a little about
it in the next few minutes, the
first big problem within what
is to complete vision, the classification of
images,
the first thing that I try to solve
within  of this field to say for
example in the case of the photo if there is
a cat there or there is not a saved cat well
I say where it is I do not say if there are many
cats I just want to know if
there is a cat or not this as the most basic thing
inside  of the field and we are going to see a little
more of that later on
and one level higher is what is
called offset detection, the
object detection part and this does have
other types of complexities because here it is not
only important to say whether or not there is a  cat
in the photo but where is it and this is going to
have a lot of problems that I am going to
have to solve
but maybe that is not enough for my application
and I have to go one step further I
drew a containing rectangle in the
ca  so before if we are seeing it but
there is a lot of background that I am taking
as a cat and there is part of expenses that I
am not taking in the
containing rectangle the reality are not
rectangles the objects so there
I can go to what is called image
segmentation here a little  what he tried to
answer is what kind is each pixel
ok what is a cat what is not a cat what background does
it follow what is grass etc and
this is a bit today the state
of the art instant segmentation of this
also some more locations very
interesting I'm seeing I'm
now back in the car I
'm driving I'm just driving at 90 kilometers per
hour on the road to me I don't I don't it doesn't help me to
know if all those pixels
in front of me are cars I'm going to tell you
knowing which car is coming which car is
crossing the street and which one is in the same
direction as me and at what speed
each one is moving that is solved a bit with the
case of instance segmentation of which
instance of which class is cad  I
not only put a label on picks but
also separated them from each other
but as a human I can do more
complex things than this and I'm going to want to
teach those more complex things to the
computer that's fine there we come to
what is called without recognition I'm
seeing  people in front chairs
lights camera good perfect I'm in
this looking at an auditorium here I'm
looking at a computer chairs at a table
I'm looking at an office the objects by
themselves there are times when it's not enough
for me to make a decision to be able to
say where I am it matters to me  everything
together and that is attacked with this field with
this one that is without recognition
and to see a little how all
this works from behind we are going to try to
understand what the computer sees
because at the end of the day all these are
ones and zeros  that the computer has
to interpret in order to carry
out an appoggiatura classification
a detection or whatever the
computer is nothing more than a matrix
when it sees an image  generate a
width by height matrix of the image where
each of the pixels of the image does not
contain more than the information of the
amount of light that is seen,
not how dark or how bright it is, and
we see that here  in the example with the
number 8, which is where each pixel is seen,
but this is only a black and
white image and this does not manage to represent, for
example, what color images are,
color images that could be a
little more complex, no  For the
computer, they are more than matrices of
width width by height by 3, where 3
represents red, green and blue, the
amount of light of each one of them,
because I know that with that, being able to
build any image is the rgb of
the  image is fine
and all this field all these problems
that I am mentioning I am going to try
to solve with neural networks because
they are very good at solving
these problems because they are very good
at generalizing not only based on
rules
and s  and it was left to us the day before, I
simply comment for those
who do not know that they do not have much
experience that neural networks are
organized in fields I have a first
layer where I have the input that
bashar layer always has a fixed size
once I define a network  Neurons are
usually vectors, means of size n x 1, and
they will go through successive layers trying
to extract more and more information, more
relevant attributes, more and more
complex attributes of what I am seeing,
until in the end I can arrive at a
prediction, a classification, and I can
Say, for example, I'm looking at a cat,
I'm looking at a car, I'm looking at a
soccer ball, that's fine, particularly
with neural networks, we're going to
work with a subfield that is
convolution neural networks, it's for
everything that is computer vision, cnn
goes  to find many times out there
because the conventional ones that what
conventional networks have are
those that take advantage of special information
It turns out that an image has a
lot of spatial information. It matters a lot
what pixel is next to what pixel. If
I disorganized it, how can I be
doing this image in the shorts?
I said that my network needs
vectors at the entrance, I lose
information because it is very difficult for me to be able to
say that I am seeing a baby there
when if I see them all together, it
has another meaning, it is much
easier for me to interpret that then with the
seizures, which are nothing more  with an
operation between matrices I am going to try to
extract this information from the image and
how am I going to do that I already have an
image in this case a house and I am going to
take a segment of the image a
rectangle of the image in the
upper left corner  and I'm going to apply a
filter I'm going to apply a combo solution
with a filter the masculine composition
of product and sum of network from quadrant to
quadrant the both matrice  s saved and
that what I am going to look for with that I what
I am looking for is, for example, I know this from
a human sense that I am using
to be able to exemplify all this I
am looking for a house and the houses of
a diagonal in this sense a
diagonal  in this sense and they have two
verticals now I can roughly
say that I found that shape I found
a house I am going to use a filter that
will look for the diagonals in this
sense
and when I find a diagonal that is
the red rectangle that you see  there it is going to be
activated, that is going to stand out a lot,
I am going to add that to the other
activations of the other patterns that
I am looking for and when I find that
pattern of diagonal vertical and
vertical diagonal I will be able to conclude that
I found a cause
at a low level  a little this is what it does
this is how it is joined with convolution that is
applied to an image and what we are
seeing is an image and the filter that
moves by applying convolution I
multiply  when and adding is fine I have
to be careful with the edges
for example with the distance that I
move but that is the padding those the
straits and work with that sure they
are aware it
is fine a little high level we saw what
the computer sees and  I am going to try to
use that information to be able to solve
the problems that you raised before, but what
does the computer see? What does the
computer really see? For example, it is
fine. Here I am showing you the
intermediate results of the
activations of the
different layers of the different  filters
of a convolution network here what
I did was draw a number two by hand
and apply a convolution network to the one that
is trained to detect numbers from
0 to 9 it's fine
I don't know if you notice but I already eat the game
of the later layer  if they go from the bottom
to the top, it no longer makes
human sense, I can't say that I have
a 2, but nevertheless, if the computer
sees that, it says 2, it's fine if I eliminated
t  all the previous part I don't even know if you
notice in a moment it becomes a
vector remember that I told you that
vectors for me were important those
zeros and ones that you see up there
those blue and dark ones mean a 2
for the computer that predicts  well it
's here I don't know if with the light of
recording it well but it predicts first it's a 2
and if it's not a 2
if it's still not good then why are
we showing this I don't have diagonals
at home I can't find diagonals I
find these patterns I  when I entered it
did not let the computer find
what filters it has to
use to activate in this way
so that when it sees a 2 I classified myself
correctly well we are doing well
object detection we are going to talk a
little more about that I told him that  this
is a little more complex than just the
classification because because here I have
to say six things in total when
I want to classify an object that if
the class that it is is a dog it is a cat
I think that assigning a trust I am 99%
sure that it is a dog or that it is a cat
but I also have to say the
containing rectangle and that I am going to
tell it by saying the
x and y coordinates of the rectangle of the origin of
the upper left part and  the width and
height of that containing rectangle and
this is actually a difficult problem
because all this is
supervised learning and I have to teach
the computer with examples and that
means I have the image and tell it
this is the rectangle that I want you to
tell me when I classify I show you
this image
which is the best container rectangle
to contain a cat because I can make a
good decision where I can say like the
whole cat but I will be taking
sections of the mud or the bottom or take
something smaller and I am sure  that I only
drink cat but I'm sure there are things left
out the tail can be left out for me
a little taking the decision, for
example, to say
the cat I'm going to say that to  there's a cat
and that's enough for me that's fine this
will depend a lot on the application that
you are facing and it is a
decision that you are going to have to
make when labeling the data
and if you are lucky it will have to be done by
your  ships may go through the entire
training process and discover that they
mislabeled and have to take the
other criterion and start from scratch
that has a fixed-size input to
have to solve complex things like
objects of different sizes because
remember I'm passing that filter  that
fixed that filter once I train to be
able to decree things then I am going to
have to solve this type of
complexities that we simply love
to comment on what comes next I tell you
that what is usually done many
times is not to change the size  of the
network but the size of the image is changed
and processed in the same image by
the network up to a total of 64 times it is
usually used a lot is fine
and a little history  ia of all this all
this can be said that it was born back in
2001 with violas jones who computed an
algorithm by hand that measured the changes and
the directions of
the light intensity and with that they managed
by hand to say finding faces is  well
as they did they said the eye is dark and
then it is light and then
it is dark again that is concentrated
when they are not served there the mouse in the
inside of the red oval that I can
find it that way once I
find that pattern find the  pattern
of the mouth and the drna said they can
contract callas this evolves to
the hong algorithm and this
ordered gradients gram that manages not to be
computed by hand but by computer
finding more complex objects than just
faces is fine this worked very well
and it was the  first
commercial applications that there were of all this because
of the response time that it had lent to
me it was not enough
because because I want to use
convolution networks to tell them  We say that they are very
important, very good, and that is where the cnn algorithm is born.
You are cnn means laughter. You see
the neural network as an illusion and what
it does is peace, it chooses
candidate regions and passes them through a convolution network,
so it has a total
of 2000 regions.  candidates from
a single image and he applies the
conventional network to each one of them and says
here the object I am looking for is either there or not, that
's fine and to choose those
two thousand because two thousand because it works for him
in practice he is  the paper
I would have chosen at least 2048 but
2000 worked for them and this field
followed a lot that is why it uses the
selective search algorithm which is
what it does, it breaks the image into
very small proportions and groups it
into increasingly larger sections
in  function of the color of the
texture and so on until you are left with only
these 2,000 candidate regions to
which you applied the convolution network to
then this looks like this I have the photo I
go through  the regional labor movement proposal
this is the selective search I am left with
different regions applied it in the
convolution network when I extract the attributes
there we see something similar to what was seen
with the 2 represented differently
the steps with a dense layer does not average
puts detail  that but that is what
ends up getting from the
attributes that I find if this is a
dog a cat and with what precision it is
fine
but it turns out that this was very slow it
processed a frame every 50 seconds that
is very very slow we return to the example the
car that drives osorio then
what is called spp net space is born the pyramid
pooling network is ok that is what
it does it says ok I extract the
region and pass it through the convolution network
when it moves me a little I extract another region
that is  very similar to the previous one and the
grandmother went on to fly from convolution to
that is very slow because passing it through
the conventional network is
computationally expensive so what I
do there is change  the order in which I
do things passed the entire photo through a
convolution network and only later
separated it into the candidate regions
that change wow let's say it is very silly it
achieves a very rare very large increase
the speed that allows me to improve a
lot
is called special  pyramid pooling because it
takes this is the scaling of 64 times
builds the
image that passes through the network as if it were a pyramid to be
able to find objects of different
sizes large and small without having to
train to find large
and small objects
but this was still  slow
for me also this was not enough for me and
that is where fast rcn was born they are going to say that in
this field we are very bad with
names
this is rcn but a little faster and I
know what it does to go faster than
that  pp net which at the same time was faster
than rcn remains planted in a
particular case of s&p in the particular case
in which I do not scale the image
I have a single image that I pass through  do
this this has the consequence that
for those more knowledgeable the
back propagate algorithm can indeed be
trained in its entirety it turns out that before I
had to train the network in parts
now I don't do that anymore and that
allows me even though I would think I
lose  precision on large and
small objects train so much better that it
compensates me for the loss of precision on
that side and at the same time it gained in speed that
's fine
this was still slow for me and it was born
faster rcn this is another algorithm I don't know
if you will notice the difference from the diaco
before this day po where the only thing
that changes is the rp in the
proposal network region is fine now that
the selective search algorithm passed is
the one that found the regions by
texture by color it became my
bottleneck it was very slow and  given that
networks like luz era are
solving so many problems for them, I put a
convolution network to do the same thing
that the algorithm did is electric
shorts to find those is  As you network those
candidate reactions and with these
changes that seem quite you when
once you count in this way if you
want, you managed to go from a speed of
one frame every 50 seconds to one frame
every zero with two seconds this is almost
real time
this is  250 times faster than when
I started, that's fine, that's a bit of the
evolution of this whole field,
but this was for
object detection and I might want to go through the
image segmentation part, that is,
pixel by pixel, all of this here in a few
most iconic algorithms within all
this some more used is more rcn than
the only thing it does is stand above
the above and once it has the
appeal container rectangle it applies a
binary mask where it says this pixel
of the container rectangle not of the entire
image  it is or it is not the object you are
looking for and with that he managed to have
results like this one is good a little
what he gained there is I stand on all of the
above and at the end of everything he added this
processing
and it turns out that this was still not
quite fast for me I want to go
faster because these applications that I
have require it and what they call
the 5 elliot of ssd texts is an
object detector field that may
go against  from practice one of the
most popular within this that what
different fans of the sector present
and why they are called that but because they
try to wash the image or only
once until now I had to do with
the computer in the image many  times
to be able to process it and extra the
information that I was looking for with this that they
seek to gain a lot in speed and as a
great difference from all the previous ones that
what they propose until now we have been
treating the object detection problem
as a classification problem
I have this rectangle of containers
I have this image, this candidate region,
and here I tell you if
the object you are looking for is there or not. Now
with the SSDs, what we do is
plan  Let's start with a regression problem.
I have a candidate region to have the
object, but that's only at the beginning. I
tell you, look, you have to move with this
offset to this side. That's where you will
find the object you are looking for,
so it becomes a linear problem.
They work with this in core boxes, they are
anchors in some way that they
can move quite freely
and the ssd actually has the
yolo standard in some way it is one of the
fastest most popular networks there is
for all this where here the  we see in
practice notice how I only have a
few objects that an
encounter finds everything I find only what
enters the network people ties
chairs see how it is trained to
find chairs and in the car you find
chairs it does not find the car for example it
does not find a steering wheel etc.  notice how it
works quite quickly to go from one
frame every 50 seconds to this is a very
important evolution and a bit so
that you have an idea of ​​the  evolution so that you
understand how fast
all this is moving back in 2001
in that algorithm of seeing jonso the one
who told you for the first time that he
finds computing by hand on the faces
etc. 2005 was born with this that manages to
generalize this  for something more than just
faces back in 2012 is when we
positioned in some way the boom of
deep learning what does this mean that
there where facebook google amazon
etc. they start
to market things that allow us to
use the gpu
the networks like the library with tensor
flow python and everything is
2014 the paper of rcn n is published that
the very slow we spoke the beginning
that was the basis of all the more 2015
fast rcn and I the 2016 faster rcn n and I
read b2 which was the one we just saw in
practice  last year more rcn and I saw
3 a peculiarity of this field is
that this is being investigated by facebook
this is still being thrown by google publishes in
the paper and from weeks to days
to months  s we have the git captcha also
published with all this and this is already
happening in production we are seeing an
amazing speed between going from the
academy to the industry that I think we
have to take advantage of and notice how
silly some of these changes were from one
algorithm to the  next I did not think
about all the possibilities that
are still not explored within this field
know that a constant that we are going to
have within all this is that we are going to
look for computationally
efficient algorithms always think about the car
that drives itself at 90 kilometers per
time that you have to make a decision in
fractions of a second
this means that I am not going to be
exact in order to be fast but to have
to choose a compromise that will be
determined by my application of how
fast and how precise today luckily
already  even some benchmarks of all
this I don't have to go out and measure all
the algorithms to see which one works for me
more or less with a bit of con  knowledge
of the practice I can already know this note
that I don't know if you get to see there the
algorithms based on faster rcn are
a good compromise between precision this
has different colleges it is measured with
different test data is that they
are much faster but not as
precise even know that they behave
differently with large and small objects they are
going to have to choose specifically
for their application that they are working
with, with which algorithm they begin to work,
yes, much more the seizures and Paula,
I am going to tell you a little more about all
this,
hello me  listen
barbara thank you very much now we are going to
comment a little about what we do when
we get a problem of this kind
this comes to me at the company or do they have their
companies by internal initiative the
first thing they have to ask is
this I am going to build it from scratch or  I'm going to
buy a ready-made solution I'm going to put together
a model like this and I've made this using
everything that rodrigo was commenting on
I'm going to start from this  Some solutions
that the ecosystem has available here
are the big companies like google
amazon ibm that offer solutions
already pre-assembled in some way that
we can use this has
advantages of being able to get out quickly to be able to
do a quick proof of concept perhaps it
has disadvantages that  when I am
working with something very particular with
a very particular problem, perhaps it is not
enough for me and I need to assemble my model and be
able to tune it and be able to train it
so that it is more specific if I am
detecting faces, for example in a photo,
say well in the face
well perhaps  that is a more
generic problem and I can have applications of
these that I can compare in some
way that work well and that perhaps
I am going to use there is always a
compromise between what is fast, more expensive
or cheaper and the precision in which
I obtain  truth in the result that I have
my model then as I commented
within the microsoft ecosystem it
has centr  you with stylize
times you have this service this one from
computer vision also has this
google vision pencil where
you can also find some things although
it finds this generic questions
for example well if there are faces but if they
are happy things that style when I
want to detect  a specific product
of a good client layers that there is already
more complicated with a solution of this
style it works for me watson is also
inside all the apps and watson
has a visual recognition one where
it can also do things of
that style and  also this amazon has
recognition that good that this one also
finds generic things and you can
do something else
what happens when I decide well
the ecosystem that is being put
together is great that is also evolving very
fast they are changing and improving the
apis one maybe it helps me  for one thing
others for others this but what happens
when it is not enough and I have to
build my model to do it  there in cause to
build it from scratch then a little the
steps that we need to follow in this
implementation would be first to get
the data no this is like the first step
that we have to have is to see with our
client or see in the company where
we are going to get data who  it is going to
label them how are we going to do with that and
this is supervised learning we had
said that it learns from the data so it
is necessary for me to label them and say
where the object I am looking for is
for example here in this case we were
putting together a math recognizer  And well,
there we have to define, in addition to having
to go photo by photo to mark
where the mate is, I have to make
decisions, for example, does the mate include
the light bulb or do I not include the light bulb?
Here it can be as Rodrigo commented
that the ticket is good  It's a model I
trained and then I realized that I did
n't really have to stop the light bulb
because if it doesn't get confused with a glass, for
example, it
's important, it's relev  Before and testing
this type of thing, it is a very important point to
have well-labeled data
because it is what it will teach my
models.
one more step and
we even work with an
instance segmentation problem as
rodrigo commented here we have that in each pixel that is to
say what class the object is this is
much more laborious it takes us much more
work to be able to label this type of
this type of problem even a  Another
step is when we have to label
things from a specific domain so
that I have specialized knowledge.
This happens a lot with
medical images.
I cannot label which parts of a
lung are cancerous or have
a problem. She needed a
specialized doctor who knows how to read.  do this
then, in addition to being a task that
takes time to do many times, it is
also a task that  it requires
specialized expensive hours in some
way
there are some tools that
can help us do this type of thing
google had announced that it was
releasing a tool to annotate
there is also super vice lides another one here they are
going to help us to do the
bulk I would say  well, the bowl is
more or less in this section but
after all the fine details and good
that I have to go do it, right,
I still have to go to this one and correct what the tool
is helping me in some
way, that is  for the
time being it is still such an
important task and it takes time to
consider it no no this not take it
for granted but it must be planned
very well when we are going to face a
problem of this type
data label spend a good
percentage of the budget of the  project
getting this photos tagging the
and anyway they are not enough for me the same
I want this I want to improve the precision
for what pr  needed more photos so
here what is usually used exactly
vision is to grab a mediate set to
do that I already have labeled and
prepared and try to increase it
from that generate these images and
new things with which I can train
my network
then if I  I am this, for example, in
this example, I have dogs, if I am
taking photos of dogs, I do not want an
unemployed person, so I take the photo from close to
far, in a corner of the image, in the
center with more light, with less light,
so I usually use libraries that  They
allow me to do this type of thing and
rotate it, zoom it in, move it away, change the
intensity of light colors, this is
different, different questions, for
this there are libraries that are python that since
they can be used and that
return results like this in this
style, anyway, I have to
do this  true because if you see in the
image here we have these some
animals that were left this blue
for example this here so that it makes no
sense  tido and I have to debug which
are the images with which I
am really going to train the algorithm, remember
that it is important with which images I enter
not because that is what is going to
determine to what precision I can later
reach
another thing that can be done  it is to
make geometric deformations in the
images in this case it is a company I
use it for a competition this with
medical images there are many competitions
that attack medical problems and
well there was an accepted fact with this
these are cells they have this
label come from this side  it is the data
as labeled and what I mean
was to say well it makes sense that I
make small deformations to the image
and the label so with this I am
expanding mediate set because I have more
images with this geometric information
along with its label and well and thanks
to this they managed to win a couple of
competitions using this type of
techniques this type of training in
data set  s
there is also
another possibility that is to use
neural networks to generate images these
these images are generated by
computer they are not real birds
but they are generated by a network this
gun is called generates adversarial networks
that what they do is good to learn how to
generate certain  type of
images then perhaps in some cases it
can be useful to train a network that
generates images for me to be able to increase
media sets without having to go out
and take photos and things and label them and with
meanings these types of networks really
have impressive results I mean
the birds can be seen  really very real
for example in this example
once I have the assets data that
increases I have to define this all I
had to do in that regard I have
to go to the model selection
everything that rodrigo commented faster rcn of
more +3 nn  let it be let's say in a way
I have to define what the
architecture of my network is going to be if I have to
take there is one of  definition to which it
suits me more than this one has
personal speed and fast enough
for my application and finally
one thing we usually do is use
transfer learning
for those who do not know it enter the room
and what it tries to do is re-use
information to take advantage of  this
training that I already did in another network
to use it in my network so this how it
works there is this on the internet
in bng and it's fine finally a
few networks so they were already
trained with a data set of
huge photos now what happens  it is expensive to have
the rate it is big if it is expensive to train
also true to this the computation of that
then we try to reuse what
other people have already done be with more
generic things and on top of that
training that I recognized
I train again  for my
specific problem then I am somehow re-
leveraging
real-world features and
things that network learned but re-
used for me  specific problem,
then transforming into is something to
take into account and that is used a
lot in everything that is to complete the vision
for this type of model,
once it is done, it is good that I have already chosen
what my model is that I saw, it was going to be
applied both  To my friend, not that I have
all these kinds of things already
defined, I have to select a
back-end here, usually the ones that are
being used the most are tensó flow and pay
touch tensors, a bookstore that he and see
google and that's good and that drives
somehow google recently
released version 2 of this tense flow
how good it improves some
mobile portability issues and
yes to go into production of these
models to be able to get them out to production
and one is really very good and above
all what it is  very important also
this is that there are many examples there this one
has a documentation many people who
are working with this and that helps us to
be able to reuse this and get
out of it quickly  somehow this one with
this payton is another one that was
also being used a lot has
suddenly charged in the last year or a little
more it is a little more powerful it is
driven by facebook above all and
well it is also another of the
alternatives that we can  To use
the usual stack a little to be able to work with
these things is to have a back-end, for
example, tenso flow. In this case, we can
use, for example, what heras is, which is a
framework that
makes it easier to program these neural networks.
the layers that
rodrigo commented on, for example, the
alex convolution layers or things like that,
instead of working with
directly content tensors, it is not possible to
work with this library because the
nomenclature and annotation is
simpler, if we do not want to do things that are
too strange, it works  use this one that
was good and above that it
will just come what is my
kind application what I want to do I want to
detect this bo
I don't know what it is for the company, for example,
once I have all that already defined, that's when
the
training part actually comes, I can actually start
training the network and this is
when maybe it's where we are,
we have to sit down and wait,
we have to take a nap because
really this takes hours and
so it is important to choose the
appropriate hardware to train many
times we are tempted to say well I
train on my computer and
see how it goes maybe it is better to use a
cloud this is very easy to use this
I spoke bs or some  another
and really, that is, the speeds
increase a lot, it can be the
difference between reaching a delivery or
not, for example, then look at
what the needs are, use
the appropriate hardware, it is worth
this time of life and being able to stretch
on models and try this more
enshrined
among the options there is this cpu gpu
multi gpu cluster each one has each
one has its complexities but well
there are a lot  variety of jars to be able to
use and be able to accelerate these
processes of this training time
while we train it is convenient to
use some tools such
as tensor board that shows us
how that training
comes suddenly comes to mind according to a
plateau and it is not improving the
accuracy of the model doesn't change well I
want to know I don't want to wait three
more hours for the training to finish
and lose all that computation time
before realizing that kind of
thing so it's convenient to use
tools that are monitoring in
some way how it's going  forming
training if it is really
serving it is improving the model
it is also important to define
appropriate metrics if in this case
we are working with
object detection for example we usually use the
intersection on the union here what happens
I want to detect the green square if
it  come so it's the father's poster
right I de re  Pente I can I
can detect something inside the poster
this very small father and that
indeed if those poster stop
but I missed a good portion of the
poster it is not good or suddenly I can
find all the image that is in
my container towards the whole  image
yes there is sure it is to the father's poster
too but in reality I am
including within what I am
selecting as my region of interest
a lot of things that are not so
what is usually used is the
intersection over the union that is, how much
part  This is true, it really
intersects with the label that I have,
so, summarizing a bit, what
would these implementation steps be,
we saw that first I have to get
the data, this is very important and
they are not in the underestimates, I have to
write them down, this is  a task that takes
a long time there are tools that
can help us and sometimes it is difficult
because we have to get
specialized people  that I can do it but
well it is also possible
then I can apply techniques to increase
jce jones as we saw and it is good that
they are really useful even
with more innovative things like
this networks will use these guns that
generated images so as to be able
to also increase mediaset then I
select which one  it is the architecture this
is a very important part and
suddenly here I have to go and come back I have
to integrate in this process to see
which is the best architecture
I can apply transfer learning I did
a little research on google to see what
things that had similar problems
you can use you must select the back-end
to then just after that you can
train and be able to measure who is the
person of my model and start
integrating nothing on that
and well it's just like some
final message let's say there are many
super interesting problems this for
to be able to deal within what
this field is, there are a few people who
are real  mind working on this serves
there is a lot of opportunity to
develop in this field it is very
fun it is not that difficult and there are many
things on the internet that there are really many
tutorials there are many online courses
that are good there are many
opportunities so those who are
with a  With little enthusiasm we invite you to
dare to try this entry into this
field and well we listen to your
questions and thank you very much for
listening to us
well questions
we have is a bit complicated a little
show if you want us to comment a
little on some that we have worked
on counterfeit detection for example it
turns out  that these gan networks are super
interesting but they can also be
dangerous they are used to falsify
images and I want to be able to counteract
that they are very good and so that we
work together with some client this
client in particular and israel- try
to find the falsification within
the image try to detect that kind of
thing another  type of problems that
we worked on that was even in one of
the days after that is the issue of image
segmentation for surgeries
I don't know if they saw power if a little ugly
that's why we asked for the organ with the
operation with the medical things that we
worked on  but a US client within the
framework of a medical competition is what we
wanted to pass was to be able to identify the
artery the organ the medical instrument
has a lot of complexities for
example how do I find the
suture thread within that image
and that is where one puts  all the
intelligence to say ok is the
white thread and everything I'm seeing inside
the red body I can apply a
red filter before increasing this
within a network applications within
this there are several super interesting ones we
have had to work on some we
are still working on  others those a little that
we can comment on
is another question
yes excuse me just a person I
know who is working on what it is
everything that is food I was
wondering if it is possible by
detecting images of one of a plate to be
able to analyze and deduce portions, that is,
the type of food I do not know about rice for
example and the portions will it be possible that
a priori I dare to tell you that  yes, but
like everything in this field, you have to
experiment, you have to see what
data there is that we have to work on, it is
a problem that without a doubt we
would dare to attack, it is super
interesting,
cobas wants to ask you about the
project that exists, either as  they are
reviewing what
to dig with it is being handled and if it
is theirs if they train it top up
outside how they deal with that
usually in the cloud we prefer
double s
we are completely agnostic in this
regard but it works well it gives us good
results some things  that we work
now exactly the name of the provider
but there are some services above w s
that pick up
double s spot machines with all the  to configuration they already
raise everything for training the
machine is born trains to give the result
of what it saves and the machine dies that is
good when you are working on
training days when each dollar
costs you 25 dollars each hour of
training costs you 25 dollars and
when you have to train two or three
models in parallel because if not you don't
reach the delivery date
I know people who are buying their
hardware to train it because it is
cheaper I know that some gpu some
of those not very expensive things must cost
fifteen hundred dollars  she feels dignified she
didn't have to speak I recommend spending
the hardware whenever possible we
all Latin Americans have a tendency
to want to save on this type of thing
it ends up being more expensive and the
values ​​from the time you have your
team standing while you train for hours
that the developer may not be
doing anything else is worth it at the end
of the day
going back to the previous question a
comment I remembered a problem in
us we are not working with a
company that is a friend of ours from Uruguay
actually they are trying to detect the
lime in trucks that entered
recycling plants and the amount of aluminum and
the amount of that type of thing to do
with them  The experiment did not go very
well because of the quality of the data they
had, they were integrating it, it is
difficult, it is interesting, it can be
very good talk, it is a question at the
time of making the inference, that is,
once the model was already trained in
gpu or with  amazon what hardware
do they use to make the inference do they use some
mobile they use raspberry or some gpu
you don't look like a gpu to make an
inference it all depends a bit on the
application you are working on the
comments that paula recently said about the
version of densos flow 20 is that what  made it
much more portable to be able to get
differences in tensor flow series the
tensor flow light that allows you to run
a raspberry pi in u  On a cell phone you can
do very interesting things on
really small devices, it
depends on the application, always the car
that is driven on the very easy example,
for all this they are developing
specialized soaps, follow a lot, I
recommend envy, envy is a
company that I think is going to grow a
lot  they are manufacturing
specialized chips for
artificial intelligence processing and that is what
is used because that is what allows you
the response times of fractions
of a second that you need there if you think
that this is a face detector it will
run on any android  have
no last problems
[Music]